à
l'école St-Louis de Gonzague,
sur le Plateau Mont-Royal,
grâce à la persévérance
d'une enseignante de 6e année.
Anne-Louise Despatie.
La livraison est un peu tardive,
et l'installation plutôt
complexe.
- Il y a tout le temps
des délais au niveau des C
de services scolaire, Et c'est
correct, dans le fond, ils font
leur travail Ils ont dû refaire
des soumissions avec les prix
actuels du béton, le prix des
matériaux. Et il f a a a aussi
attendre que ce soit installé
pendant une journée pedagogique
pour que ce soit sécuritaire
pour les enfants.
- Depuis trois ans,
l'enseigMaMaMaMarie Emilie Gagné
rêve de ces modules pour
la cour de l'École Saint-Louis
de Gonzague.
MARIE EMILIE GAGNÉ, enseignante,
École Saint-Louis-de-Gonzague
j j j je voulais avoir un
skatepark pour donner mes cours
parascolaires de skate et pour
que les enfants aient un endroit
sécuritaire pour pratiquer
aussi. Donc, des modules de bas
niveau pour leur permettre
d'évoluer.
- Il n'y a pratiquement pas
de parcours à Montréal
pour les débutants en planche
à roulettes. C'est po u u u un
sport attrayant qui a même fait
son entrée aux Jeux Olympiques
en 2021 à Tokyo.
- J'ai plutôt, comme... essayé
le skate, parce que je connais
pas vraiment ça, mais j'aimerais
ça en apprendre davantage.
- Ce que j'aime dans le skate :
faire le c c c c c'est amusant
parce que tu glisses et t'as
l'impression, de, genre...
ouais, c'est vraiment une bonne
sensation.
- Leur enseignante y voit
beaucoup plus que le côté cool.
- C'est des classes de 3e à 6e
année, et c'est un bon âge pour
apprendre. Ils sont assez
grands, assez matures pour être
capables capables d'être
focalisés longtemps, concentrési
du placement du corps.
- Ouh, yeah!
- En encourageant les jeunes
à répssssssssssssais, à tomber
sans se blesser, à perséverer,
l'enseignante de 40 ans
a retrouvé des valeurs
qui lui sont chères.LeLeLeLeLeLa
perséverance, de la confiance
en soi, de l'entraide se
retrouvaient aussi a l'école.Jes
faire un parascolaire de planche
à roulettes à l'école pour
amener ces valeussssss
un sport qui, pour moi,
est un sport complet?
- Il y a des écoles où il y a
des équipes de sport. Mais nous,
c'est comme si on était une
école de skate, parce qu'on a
un skatepark et on a des cours.
- L'école prête les planches
à roulettes et les casques
aux élèves. Le projet réalisé
par une firme spécialisée
représente un investissement
de 31 000 dollars.
- J'ai eu un petit montant
de l'arrondissement, ici
du Plateau Mont-Royal,
et le reste, c'est des fonds,
dans le fond, qui avaient été
accumulés par les parents
des les années p
MONIQUE FOURNIER, parent & prés.
du CA, Saint-Louis-de-Gonzague
- C'est une passionnée,
alors je pense qu'elle nous a
tous con
(rire)
C'est déjà un projet qui a fait
des heureux. Parce qu'en fin de
semaine, je suis passée samedi
j j j j j j j j'ai eu
le plaisir de voir des petites
familles et des enfants
en trotinettes essayer
le skatepark. Donc, ça m'a
convaincue que c'était une bonne
idée, finalement, et que ça
corresondait à un besoin.
- J'ai découvert le skate à
35 ans, suite au défi d'une amie
qui m'a dit de reussir un ollie,
qui est une figure en skate
où on doit faire sauter
notre planche dans les airs,
en une semaine. Et j'ai réussi!
Et je suis vraiment tombée
en amour avec le sport.
- C'est cool parce que tu peux
venir skater, la fin de semaine,
et puis ça donne des plus larges
espaces pour faire des figures.
- Il y a eu déjà quelques
plaintes au sujet du bruit
provoqué par les joints
métalliques. L'hiver laissera
un peu de temps pour trouver
un accommodement.
- Oui, Arthur!
Ici Anne-Louise Despaties,
Radio-Canada, Montréa